welcome to the recruitment roller
coaster podcast my name is
hisham azuz today i'm joined by mark
bracknell
who is the co-founder of theo james
recruitment
they are a manufacturing engineering
recruiting agency based
in county durham there's eight people in
the business
and they've been going for coming up to
five years
mark thanks for joining me from uh your
conservatory in in
county durham thank you for having me
yeah i appreciate it um
obviously we've been speaking for a
little while exchanged messages
over the last couple years so definitely
excited to
uncover your journey um so far obviously
we're going to really focus on
you being a recruitment business owner
and your
journey in leading your own recruitment
business but
let's we're always like to start is how
you got into recruitment
let's start there yeah well you'll be
pleased to know that i didn't actually
fall into
it like most people so i was one of the
uh the rare few that proactively tried
to get into recruitment so uh
so not not your normal story to be told
um so i'm richie from sheffield
went to uh university of sunderland um
to do
a a tv and radio production degree
oh wow like all your top entrepreneurs
um so who
did that um i kind of did that because i
didn't really that time knew what i
wanted to do
i knew i wanted to go to university just
for the experience of
so living away um doing that and
did the course um thought about what i
didn't want against media
um really really didn't enjoy that as a
sort of career i knew that was gonna be
the case
applied for a few recruitment roles um i
mean thinking back
it's probably because in my year out
before university i worked in offices
but i worked through
a recruitment firm um how much one it
was at that time but i
remember sitting in there a couple
occasions um actually
registering it and just quite enjoying
the atmosphere the environment it was
it was professional but it was it was
buzzy and people
seemed to be sort of working hard but
having fun and that really sort of
resonated with me
so um applied for numerous roles
um for zero return no interviews no
feedback
anything at all um did what most
students do and panic and look back at
sort of
how can i state uni so i found a course
which was a
a qualification in careers guidance
which was a one-year post-grad course
and one of the offshoots of that was
actually recruitment so
did that for a year and absolutely loved
it um i learned more
in that year than i probably did it
three years previously and it was
mainly focused around um helping sort of
16 to 18 year olds get into education or
employment um
i was doing interview tips i always
learned i'd be with people i guess
um i did a three-month stint at a youth
offending prison
um and i loved that oh wow he was really
good he was he was challenging it was
obviously
saw some some great stuff but i loved it
um and i think
there was a time where i would have
thought about getting into youth
offending but
there's no money in it um the the
funding literally fell out of it
and i sort of went back and thought
right okay let's let's start applying
for recruitment so
pretty much the first job i applied for
um got an interview for
um it was a firm called
trent pierce and they were a spin-off of
um i think they called jumbo now but it
was jj fox the group and basically it
was a
group of companies um all in competition
with one another
but all owned by x s3 um
people so they were but to me even a
northern lad they were
all sort of millionaire cockney white
boys
and had a i think about three or three
and a half hour interview with all of
them really really intense
um and and got the job and it was
brilliant it was a
it was a real sort of work hard play out
atmosphere like you stereotypical
regret with wall street sort of stuff
and it was just brilliant um
i couldn't have i couldn't start i don't
think at a better better company
where was that based so originally they
were based in newcastle um
so obviously i was it was it was easy
for me to to do cellular base city
center newcastle
um literally a stone throw from the big
market pubs everywhere
great great place to be in that type
environment later
they actually closed their office down
in about um 2010 i think it was and i
moved
with them to manchester and i worked and
ever in the year there manchester and
that was
a great offering sport yeah i actually
joined recruitment 2008 so
recession hit so it was uh what sector
did you go into
so i started off in um further further
education so i had a
my niche was looking at um health and
social care lecturers for
fe colleges across the uk so really
niche um
but this was 2008 and i started off and
there was no issues
um literally no issues it felt felt
quite easy
looking back you never discussed rates
now it's your first question
it just wasn't it wasn't on the agenda
it was just about the people you had and
what you said but the funding just fell
out of it you know the
recession hit hard um they pretty much
crashed out of fb and
and adapted really really quickly i
think they saw that i had a
real passion for being on the phone and
selling um i
i quite i have always enjoyed almost
taking the projection and the cat and
mouse game of sales so
they asked me to to build up a um it was
like a training function basis so
still within health and social care
basically they were private
organizations for like assessors and
tutors so it was different there was
nothing on the system there was not one
bit of there was not one company
um at all so it was starting from
scratch literally for three months was
call call call
and i think looking back that was the
best thing it could have happened to me
because
it was all i knew i was taking rejection
all day long
and i kind of learned to take the small
ones that i might even be an email
address you know i mean
the stuff that when we started the
firmware you know that that you know you
can resonate with so
that was brilliant for me and that i
built it up to a really good level um i
think later there was about three or
four people that worked
just on that on that patch so uh so yeah
it was a really really
really really good grounding because
obviously worked at that company for
just over three years
yeah really good grounding that's that's
really interesting so then
obviously and then obviously worked um
two other companies before you started
theo james yeah
um and then i guess if we were to talk
about the sort of um
role before you start theo james that
was a
core people right yeah so um just
quickly what what was your journey there
was it joined as a
obviously more experienced consultant
then or was you a leader straight away
where but by the time that you left
there what what was your role what was
you doing
i think i had a nice transition in
recruitment because the first firm was
obviously work hard play hard but
grinding whether they were 12 30
nowadays it was
incentive holidays you were abroad four
or five times a year didn't have any
responsibilities no children
no partner it was just it was just all
the cumbersome work basically i loved it
um then obviously i i joined um i think
supply desk in all honesty that was a
stop gap um
it was very very different it was to to
get back into the northeast
um for for a girl um so
met uh still with her now she's my wife
now yeah yeah
so uh yeah i had a night out in back of
northeast
um i think i probably lied and said i
was moving back to the northeast at some
stage just to get a number
and then pretty much through that life
so uh i am so
took a massive pace to pay cut to come
come back um
and it was a good firm but it just
wasn't for me it was it was almost like
glorify admin it was
teaching supply recruitment so you come
in at half seven
mitch's mrs white is off sick you put
mrs green in it was it
wasn't really the sort of
entrepreneurial side that the sales side
i enjoyed so core people was a was a
good step for me because i came in as
a senior recruitment consultant and
wasn't mind anyone
but i was obviously i was a senior
member of staff um
straight into manufacturing so no it's
no experience on
on that patch but good for him to work
for because they gave you quite a bit of
autonomy um you know
there's no one really screaming down
screaming down your neck i kind of i'd
already had quite a lot of training and
i kind of already knew what i needed to
do
um so quite in i did enjoy my time there
and it was a good
a good journey because it was a desk it
was a desk that i had well pretty much
until
very recently um it was uh essentially
working with maintenance engineers
across the north east so really nice and
had that for three years there and
obviously through theo james so
good firm to work for definitely so by
the time you left how do you manage
people
yeah so i'm i work way up to a managing
consultant so i was
i was working with um with a with a
couple of people
still i guess like a billion manager if
you like um
when i did leave i was a manager so um
i'll
probably talk in depth about it how we
started the business but i'd actually
moved over to
to construction um and was managing a
team there for a short period of time
until
um tommy and gary started start the
business um so yeah
but i didn't have years i've not i've
not had years and years of
management experience my journey through
theo james has been
it's been quite a big one it with my own
personal development to learning how to
manage people from from the mistakes i
guess
because what so what gave you and
and so obviously so you started theo
james with you
obviously gary your business partner yep
um and then i'm suddenly
you obviously showed me that there's
someone else involved as well yeah
um what gay so what what gave you the
confidence to start your own recruitment
business
let's start there because a lot of
people that's what people are most
worried about right
taking that leap taking that initial
plunge so
um what gave you the confidence
i think i'd always thought about i want
to own my own business right from the
start when i
kind of saw what the owners of the first
business i worked for i had i kind of
thought
i want that um but it kind of been on
the back burner
um so this in all honesty was more of an
opportunity i i
had to take up um so at the time
there was gary was the gary managed the
the manufacturing division
if you like i was a his assistant
manager if you like um so we
we sort of oversaw a team of seven or
eight he was a profitable partner on the
business
but we were 20 20 25 of the business the
rest of it was construction
people so that's what they've always
been famous for for 30 years
um we we were asked to to move
over to construction um he wanted
basically to become 100 a construction
firm and focus on that and drive and
grow that
which made sense and and solitude was um
and obviously it was a promotion for us
to go over there and manage big teams
but it was soul destroying because
firstly it was
i i didn't feel that passion about
construction i don't know why but i just
i didn't resonate with it
gary is an ex ops manager of a sangha
ban a big
manufacturing french firm so it's
manufacturing
is in his blood um and about two months
in
you know we we were still getting
clients callers saying can you work a
maintenance engineer job first can you
work a buy for us and we were saying
really sorry
we can't we don't work it and it was so
destroying these relationships that we
brought up from that sort of
yeah that makes sense so um i literally
looked at numbers
numbers what i built and and you know
what the team had built i thought
this is madness you know this is crazy
so um i did some math something i spoke
to
i spoke my dad first he's an accountant
very very sensible head
and even he said look you know he could
be onto something spoke to him
brother-in-law
um he's financial advisor and again you
know he backed it
took gas to the uh took guys to the pub
and said guys i said look look what
we've built in the last
12 months right even if we build half of
that they you know
we had a rough estimate of overhead we
have an idea really um because you don't
there's not that much information he's
not as much as he was now with people
like yourself on there
um well shall we do it you know we and
we knew
because what did you do in that year
what what give us a bit of confidence
yeah you know that these were sort of
three grand average fees do you mean
which is it yeah yeah
you didn't mean so that's just good for
context okay so he's not not not too bad
but no not amazing jeremy but
good enough to eastern right you know
what if we in
it's half of that and our ovaries are 20
grand we'll we'll be all right
yes we've got some freedom so took gary
the pub
um i said look what do you think and he
he
mulled it over didn't say much like he
normally doesn't said um
um leaving with me so he went oldie for
two weeks um
didn't speak to him for the whole time
unknown to me he was sat on a deck chair
ruining his oldie thinking about nothing
else basically
and he's his motivation's very different
because he's um you know
got his older knees his motivation was
retiring early where his mind was
obviously building something
um what was the age gap so gaza is 55
um i'm 35 so okay interest then it's an
age gap um decent age gap so
but i i really wanted gary to be
involved i really wanted because i knew
how good he was
he's a tremendous manager and he brings
to the business what i can never bring
because clients just resonate with him
straight away because he's one of them
you know yeah yeah it's a great story
and yeah
yeah massively so really keen to get on
board um
in that two weeks i spoke to my best pal
carl who
is an entrepreneur essentially he owns
sort of tech businesses
um he was keen to get involved he
couldn't get involved day to day
obviously because obviously his
of his work he does and he has no
experience in recruitment but
he wanted to to help us help us start up
and and um so he's a co-founder of the
business
so gas came back said let's do it um
and it all happened really quickly so
with the space of uh
a few days really we raised the company
um where'd your name come from yeah
that's a that's a terrible story so i
wish i could give you some better so um
as it happened very quickly my my wife
was pregnant um
due very very very shortly um and we
we thought we're having a boy and the
boy was gonna be called theo james
so um gaz wasn't really bothered um he
said yeah crack on it sounds like a good
name to me we didn't really think about
it that much at all
and called it theo james had a girl
um so called ella so um
i mean i have now since had a little boy
who uh who isn't
called theo because uh you know we
thought that had been done now but
but yeah so the name is nothing
basically so it's okay
and it's gone no no it's gone it's also
not ideal because obviously theo james
is an actor so if you google theo james
when
we know we're near the top um but it all
happened pretty quickly so yeah fair
enough
first couple weeks you know trying to
you know had notice in which was
obviously
a tough thing to do but you understood
um you know left on really good terms we
had a luxury because we didn't have the
covenants that most people would do
because they weren't in the space
anymore they weren't yeah because you
went into yeah that makes sense
which is part of the catalyst as to why
you considered starting your own
business right
yeah so i guess what i really like about
that is
like you clearly intentionally or not
like basically what you did there is you
you got people involved
who had skill sets that weren't your
strongest skill set right yeah so you've
got gaza
as you said he's got a great story
really understands the industry that
we're going to be recruiting for us it
can have loads of heaps of value there
great manager operations person and as
you said that isn't something that
you're um an expert in or had loads of
experience in
and then also got the other chap
involved because he's been involved in
scaling growing
businesses right so i actually love that
in terms of like
putting together a bit of a dream team
really and got people together that
adds value in their own way yeah so i
guess
always always keen to hear about it
because again it's probably the the
the year that people were most worried
about is that first year
so things will happen quite quickly yeah
what what
was that first year look like what was
the well i guess
was the plan right we need to get back
on back on the phones to people that
keep calling us
um start there and then go from there
what what happened in that first year
yeah 100 was i mean again we we the plan
for us was to pick up where we left off
two months ago
that literally that was we didn't
rethink anything above that and we we
never put a label on it i think
looking back we probably thought it was
gonna be a lifestyle business we thought
right we might have five six staff we
can
we can earn decent living we never said
that this is going to be a lifestyle
business but at the time
i think it probably was going to be so
the biggest challenge
um initially was was the database um you
know you
never you know well because you didn't
have because you had no one on a
database not a database so you know we
we were very very lean so i think we
used chameleon i um i googled free
database convenient um used that
it was we had one free account one was
was 25 quid
it was absolutely fine for what we
needed it was it was a recruitment
specific database
yeah that's the one i used that great
journal it was ideal for us so
it's part of our uh our start off so the
first challenge was was was literally
graphed in every outgod center to try
and get cvs companies contacts
everything we can assist your database
yeah yeah massively and linkedin wasn't
what it was
even then so that was a big challenge
but you know we we pulled two or three
jobs on the first day
so yeah we literally just gone right
okay
let's just sit who are our top 100
clients who we've done business with
called them picked up two three and you
know we made
at the end of the week one we made three
placements
really yeah we had uh we had so we had a
dream start i think we had four
placements
in week two we so we built about 20 to
25 grand and it was
i it was um i it was my contacts the
maintenance engineers built them
straight away
and i thought we went to the pub um i
thought you know we're gonna be
millionaires here next week guys
this is it yeah this is it this is it
and then um i remember
the week later because they're all quite
immediate starters a week later and
i was driving into work um and i
literally i checked my phone
and every one of them was was either
dropping out or looked like he was going
to drop out we had someone else count
offered
someone believe it or not had uh i had
been arrested
unbelievable it was been arrested for
stealing some copper wire this was like
a seven grand
um another one had started but said he
didn't like it and i was driving and
going
what have we done you know 20 grand is
he's often two grand when he recruiter
but 20 grand was 20 grand then
and you know you know we had no salary
and i was traveling going
you know i've just had a baby born i've
just moved into a new house
wife on material leave what have i done
and it was that was probably
one of the toughest days we've ever had
but i'm so pleased went through it
because
it helped us um helped us be a lot
tougher moving forward so
it was our first year looking back was
probably easier than
than some um we just kind of got our
heads down
i guess it's a bit like thinking back
when you don't have don't have kids when
you have kids
you look back and you had no
responsibilities it was free
it was easy and it was fun but you
wouldn't swap it to what you've got now
because
despite the fact it's harder um you're
in a better place right now
i think for us our year one was
difficult we didn't do anything
crazy building wise we weren't working
ridiculous hours
we probably did i think we did about 250
to 60 or perm
um so it was all right do you mean it
was at the time yeah and obviously with
you and gaz yeah and i'll see the other
chap as well that was what you had in
your mind right it's like right let's
see if we can do this ourselves and yeah
yeah yeah um so um
that's really interesting then so
basically the the mindset in that first
year was right let's just get money on
the board
let's actually see if we can do this we
took on the plan wasn't taken
and we're on the first year um we
actually did we um
so we actually took on uh gary's son
just to complicate matters even more so
um so i mean ross is a friend of mine he
worked um with core people not in
recruitment
um a different type of role um he'd
be redundant there so gaz picked me up
in the morning
um pretty sort of red face and said look
can i can i
ask you a big favor you know can we i
know this isn't a plan but can we look
at taking
ross on come and bring him on and
obviously i said absolutely yes so
so ross um wrestled with us probably
just from under a year although he
didn't didn't work out but he still
played a real
big part in our sort of first year in
our growth there so uh
so yeah that was that was high number
one basically so what
what happened in that first year that
you didn't expect
um i think
that probably probably personally to
care so much i think the personal
journey
um it engulfed me and i think obviously
i had a hell of a lot going on at home
you know i had
a brand new baby um my wife actually at
the time
um wasn't very well she had a hemorrhage
after after the first child so i you
know
player played to gazi he held the fall
for her for a couple of weeks which i
would just
literally have to look after every home
so i think you know looking back
um it was just how much i would care
personally how much it would take over
my life
i think i learned as time go went on to
make sure i try and switch off the
process so
it took it probably it took a hell of a
lot out of me personally that first year
just to get up and running yeah but that
being said i loved
i loved every second of it um how did it
affect your
relationship then with your partner
because i think that's because
that that's always that's again
definitely going to be something really
common that people don't expect
that yeah it you you will go to you will
wake up thinking about theo james and
you will be going to sleep thinking
about theo james the
the child you never had but yeah yeah is
the child in the form of
of your recruitment business right so
like obviously
clearly someone that was gonna support
um
your partner through really difficult
times but what did that how did that
relationship turn out if it was just
you were so engulfed with it was that
hard yeah yeah i mean she keeps being
checked but no i mean she's been uh
superb i mean incredibly supportive you
know this was
this was never her dream this was my
dream you know yeah you know she was
with me when i
didn't own a business so it's not as
though this is our our dream it's it's
mine it's
it's for them and then my why but you
know incredibly supportive
um without doubt but you know at the
same time we'll
we'll keep in check and make sure that
that i am um trying to bounce out as
much as i possibly possibly can yeah you
know she's not scared to tell me that
a non-negotiable for us has always been
i'm at home
at six o'clock to help bath the kids
that's something that's really important
to me obviously if i go on a course or
etc is fine but
but you know nine times out of ten i
will never be at work at six o'clock
um i'll always be at home i went for a
journey of
not switching off at that time i think
there's a long period of time i would be
there
but i wasn't there in mind yeah he
wasn't present no not at all so i think
um
you know but that she's been she's been
a massive part of our journey
um through me from from just making sure
that i'm focused and and
you know i i've not had any night feeds
and all the med stuff that
negotiables that he was always there for
um i think for me my
my journey with it so far because i've
found that quite hard like switching off
and
it's all encompassing right um is just
just over over communicating i think so
sometimes i've been um susceptible to
just
making the assumption that my girlfriend
understands why sometimes i've got a
work late or
like i don't know sometimes you can just
assume that they understand
why you've got to do things but they
don't
you have to you have to communicate and
have to say well that this is why this
is
remember this is why i'm doing this and
this is the sort of mission that i'm on
you are
a big reason as to why i'm putting in
this work right now and i think just
don't don't
assume that they understand why you have
to work late and all these types of
things i think it's just really
important to try and communicate
your drivers and why you're doing things
and stuff like that
that's that's what i've had to do yeah
no definitely
completely i i completely agree i think
you've got to keep yourself in check
um you you burn out as a recruiter but
you can burn out even easier as an owner
because
there's always yeah you can always be
doing something you always be doing
that's the thing
is that it's i could it's just that it's
exactly what you just said there's
always something that you could be doing
yeah yeah massively um it isn't i think
you've
and i've i've got i'm not fantastic at
it and sometimes i feel like i'm burned
now and i'll go right okay
i want to make some rules for myself
i've got to switch my phone off between
six and seven
i'll then go switch my phone to nine
o'clock because everything can wait
there's nothing
nothing everything can wait nothing can
happen at 10 pm at night which can't
wait until the morning and
it's important i've learned that but
it's taken me some time to
really learn that um i've learned that
the harder guess of really getting quite
stressed out stressed i would say
okay so going into the so obviously
second year then
obviously as you said managed to to
generate
circa 250k revenue just you you and gaz
basically
um what was the mindset going into year
two then
was it like right less less less see if
we can double that or i don't know what
was the mindset going into year two
yeah i think um so one thing that um
one thing that carl's always been very
very good at and literally from month
one is
um we we have board meetings every month
and at first i was at a board meeting
there's only two of us but no but you
know
there's only three of us in business so
we have a bourbon every month and we go
through things and
now obviously extremely crucial but even
then you know working on the business
when you're not in it is important so i
think so what was the typical just out
of interest
really quickly was it was a typical
agenda so
um typical agenda that was very
different but
at the time i think it was what went
wrong what could we do what could we do
better it was more day-to-day i would
say at the time it was more sort of how
what situations we managed um now it's
all about growth and it's all about
scaling et cetera so i think in early
days it was just
taking ourselves out the business going
for a meal same same mentality we've
been to
every single month since since day one
and just
taking some time out to analyze things
um
the greatest things well as a three we
we rarely agree
initially we've all got three very very
different opinions they can be
they're always quite heated to some
extent um i'll come away
mentally exhausted from boar means but
we always agree on her
on on some form of uh decision yeah
that's the right one yeah definitely
but i think year two we um probably the
the catalyst i would say
um was we we thought right you know what
um
i wouldn't say growth is a word but
let's try and add a couple of heads and
we advertise a role
um vicky who's with us now applied well
she actually
she she called me up and said i've seen
you've applied for you're playing for a
for a consultant would you consider me
and vicky is
she's you know the time she's just 10
years of coming experience you know we
work the closely she's the best i've
ever worked with you know
the most professional recruiter that
you'll ever meet massive cube of the
business and it was a bit like
jesus you know someone like her would
want to work for us
did you think why would she want to work
for us yeah definitely definitely i mean
that's so common yeah massively and i
think um
you know leaving a business that she'd
been for for so long
doing extremely well you know she was
she was a manager she was billing
you know this was definitely going to be
an initial step back for her
to to join us was just like wow
do you mean so i said well you know you
don't have to apply come come to the pub
now we'll talk about it so
she was hired after five minutes so that
was uh
what was your sale obviously she was
obviously motivated but
obviously because i think it's come up a
couple of times in the podcast when
you're a smaller
grown business which the majority of the
uk recruitment market is
yeah you do have those self-doubts as to
why would this person want to
work for us and sometimes that can lead
to bad hiring decisions right and
yeah like so i guess like when you had
that moment with vicky
who's obviously still with you now which
is amazing
what was that what was the sell from
your from your point then what was
was you honest how did you communicate
what fia james could be for her
i think we were very very honest i think
the big cell was probably the culture
and and
we've always been big on culture we've
probably talked more about culture than
than profit and growth and anything else
and i think we talked about the
environment
we want to build and her to be part of
it um
we've always been very very very open
honest about gary's journey you know
gary
some state's plans to to tie really um
and you know even then i communicate
with vicky to have her on board at that
stage
was massive for me because i wanted her
to be part of that journey and hopefully
be
you know be by my side when we grow that
so i think she obviously saw
some long-term growth for her there to
be part of something
um which is still very very much the
plan so um she was excited about it i
think she was probably ready for a
change
um i didn't realize that that was the
case you know but i kept in touch
just about personal stuff but i didn't
realize that she was going through
a bit of a journey there where i think
she'd probably been there for 10 years
and thought you know what maybe i'm
ready for something different
so i think her it came at a perfect time
um she had opportunities to join
businesses which were much bigger than
ours and and
much more stable hours you know we were
you know we were a small business which
you know three months three bad months
could have killed us um in actual fact
in year two we went through probably the
hardest
challenge we've ever had um i think we
got got through a stage where
looking back we got too comfortable
there was four of us
and we were four friends and i think we
just enjoyed coming to work and working
hard and then for whatever reason we
went through a sticky patch which you
can do any consultant go for a sticky
patch and we happened to go through it
all together
and looking back i think we didn't have
process in place we didn't have any
kpis well you did bill for a certain
period yeah yeah we
we we were massive in the target for
about three months and then we're sorry
looking
suddenly we've got you know we've got
staff we've got head count we've got
overheads
and that's the first time i was really
really stressed and when you've got
other people you're responsible for
yeah one thing thinking right i'll start
again or get a new job it's another
thing
thinking like i've actually taken people
out of a job now this i've i've got
responsibility to people
that's always sort of been quite heavy
on my shoulders and
i took it upon myself to be told to just
go right you know what i need to get us
out this [ __ ] so i i
i got my head down um and just went back
to basics completely
graphed the graph to grafted and i built
really well i built a commonly was but a
decent amount of money in three four
months and just pulled it out of us
and i think i probably led from the
front there and from that we start to
analyze
what works and i think we analyzed the
numbers and that's where
carl was very crucial okay right so why
were you successful how many cv's
how many calls did you make stuff that
i'd never really sort of looked at
before i just knew
what i did worked so we looked at that
and then we looked at how we can
analyze and scale the business and start
to put some some process in place so
it was probably the end of year two
where we were then successful after
after a tough period of time i think we
built about 400
perm we added maybe 150 temp um
so we did all we did okay not as much as
we should have done but we did okay
but he gave us the confidence to go
actually we could be we could be a
business here
um we could be a decent a decent
business and we can grow so i think
that's a stage where
we thought right let's we went from a
lifestyle business to maybe a slow
growth business or something yeah
how because i think a lot of people can
fall into that
i think it's quite common isn't it that
sort of when you're a smaller grown
business obviously
you you end up taking people that you do
end up having really good sort of
friendly relationship with and
it's it's really overlaps that sort of
friend and professional relationship
yeah how did you communicate that
because i feel like
obviously that will be things that
people go for even just as a billing
manager
or as an actual business owner how do
you communicate that hey guys
we need to [ __ ] up our game here like
how how did you communicate that out of
interest
i don't know if i said the words i think
it was i've never been good at hiding
stuff and i think i was visibly stressed
out true to me i think i was basically
stressing
and the way i deal with things at the
time is just to go right okay
i'm just going to graph and i think
people saw how hard i was working
and then they they they tried to
replicate that and did and worked very
hard
um so you just led by example yeah i
think that's it i've always found it
easier
my journey is i've learned to manage but
i've always found it easier to
do as i do not as i say um i'm better at
that now and i think i'm
i am better at training people and and
helping them assist them but i've always
found it easier just to lead from the
front
than tell them and communicate what to
do so i think
yeah it was literally just just getting
me get my head down and graphene should
be told
so it was less of hey guys put them in
the meeting room and be like right guys
we need [ __ ] up it here got
complacent it was more of
right i've noticed this has been going
on i need to
turn this around because i've got other
people's livelihoods here that
i'm i'm now responsible for and just led
by example that then also ended up
influencing
their actions and output um okay
so going into year three then
what processes did you start to
implement you've mentioned that word a
couple of times and i think
i think um i've had done a couple of
podcasts recently where
this word's come up a lot and i think
it's it's really important because i
think
it's what you're what you've spoken
about huge number of recruitment
businesses are
small growing businesses or have sub 10
staff
and i think um a big part of that as to
why a big reason as to why businesses
don't grow or scale is that they
typically have the mindset of we'll do
that when we get to this point or
we'll put that process in when we've hit
this milestone
and it's just come up a lot recently
where the last interview i did with
someone they
they were a five-person business but
they were implementing processes the
20-person business would have
and then when they got to 20 people they
were implementing a 50 percent business
would have do you know what i mean so
yeah i guess what what what processes
did you start implementing or how did
you
start thinking about um your business
differently and going inside year three
because that's obviously
the moment that you had that right and
what you started to do yeah definitely i
think year three for me is when we
actually start being a business
i think looking back we we i wouldn't
say what we wasted two years because you
know it was part of our journey and and
you know you learn more more things
failures um the two businesses i work
for
weren't big on processed they weren't
big on they weren't big on that side
they weren't big on analyzing what works
to be fair so we didn't you only know
what you know right
um so it's probably more it was probably
an issue more carl that said like let's
get some processes in place some
scalable process and document those
processes
and let's look at what's worked for us
in the past and that's when we looked at
my desk
um i was probably building a third of
the third of the company billings let's
let's look at it we analyzed it
and we try to scale that out um we
brought on we brought in cube19
um oh wow which which was great yeah we
haven't we've
swapped that now to one up because we
changed the call to our business but
cube 19 was was great for us
at the time because why did you why did
just out of interest why did you choose
to invest in and that's all what was you
hoping it could do for you
it was basically the analytics for one
so we can
you know we were spreadsheets we're all
spreadsheets and numbers and we
designed some brilliant spreadsheets and
you know we had graphs all sorts but
cuban team was just
we demoed and we said this this is it
this is where we can see
what we're doing right what would you
enable you to visualize the
the the sort of the things that mark was
doing on a day-to-day week month by
month basis that
would mean that if we could get more
people doing that then there's a good
chance that yeah
okay yeah exactly that in hindsight um
we probably went too kpi heavy i think
we went from from nothing to everything
you know we
we threw the the kitchen sink at it and
said right okay cv sends
calls references meetings everything
and we went hard on that but we had we
brought in cube19
uh we brought in odro which probably
changed the facebook isn't
i would say more than anything um it
changed the culture our business
um using video to betray
us and what we're about was was i think
just change the face of
theo james honestly um we also joined
the rdlc um which is probably the
probably the
the biggest catalyst for our change
moving forward because it was the first
time we were we were allowed to see
what all the businesses were doing
because you if you're in a bubble as a
recruiter yeah of course yeah i can't
see it and
yeah you don't go to networking events
if you're not a part of this type of
thing
plus i think going you know these were
majority of them with tech businesses in
london
and it was opened my eyes massively
because i think they were probably ahead
of the times to most
of our our type agencies yeah enabled us
i think to be the first movers in our
marketplace to do things like using
certain technologies like using video to
to get messages across et cetera and
using video for interview so
that was the first time for us that i
think
we start becoming a business we got
bullhorn do you mean everything seems
yeah yeah everything seems to sort of go
right okay we're a professional business
now we can scale and we can
and we can grow and it was the first
time i think we're all comfortable and
confident as a three
that we could actually bring people into
this environment and they could be
successful i would say
so you really started so it seems like
you really started part of that process
was
you invested in the tools you invested
in basically getting the foundations and
being able to be really confident with
the platform that you could offer new
employees into
theo james yeah definitely because
you've got and you've all you've got to
compete you know when you've got to sell
the business at the same time you know
anyone interviewing for
for you you know you've got to sell
division you've got to sell the company
and
and how they're going to work so i think
we um i think we brought on we were at
the end of year three
we were up to six staff um i think we
had maybe four or five that failed but
not a bad churn rate you know we had
sort of
one and two which which isn't too bad
and we brought some really good staff on
um the bulk of those are still with us
now so i think our our
year three was probably in a way our
most important year i would say
um because you know year four was
difficult internal recruitment wise but
year three you know we put
maybe about 600 pound on the ball 600
then probably 3 400 so i think we got up
to some million i think we turn over the
first time so
that was my next question how did you
invest in these tools and networks then
sort of correlate with
the actual performance of of the
business so that that obviously
increased yeah it definitely increased
we saw an increase obviously overheads
increase
and it's time jeremy you have sleeping
is nice over that but
yeah it definitely had a positive effect
on the uh
on the revenue without doubt and and how
did just quickly then before we go into
year four thinking about
year two and year three how did mark's
day change
like what what what did you end up
spending more time on training
i don't know what how did your day
change from if you think about you're
going right right we've got we've got
pretty good business here let's let's
really invest in things to
take us to the next level what how did
your your role change and what did your
day look like
so i think one of the most important
things again when year three was taking
me off a desk you know
it was a big bold move because my desk
was still there i was a solo top builder
i still have you know i'd still probably
third the billings the company it was a
desk i'd had for seven or eight years so
you know it was easier for me i guess to
build to build better so
it was the first year that i was working
on the business not in the business if
that makes sense so
what's it so it's about the very
beginning of year three you
kind of you really sort of relinquished
your desk
yeah probably probably um yeah he was to
the end of quarter one i think he was
and that was a big decision you know
that was a that was a tough for me you
know
to decide that you know to take away my
billions and go right okay
um let's just hire into it which we did
that was a big decision um
but that's what we did and my plan was
basically because we decided to go from
a lifestyle business to a
to a growth business at a time we agreed
that the only way to do that was
for me to come off a desk because i've
still got a passion for sales and
passion
passion for the training so i came off a
desk
um i attended you know lots of lots of
things with the rdlc
tried to develop myself went on various
courses personally
you know it's the first time we started
getting external trainers on board
we started investing in our staff um my
day changed i guess
just by being involved a lot more in
their activity and what they're doing
looking more the numbers and seeing what
was working see what wasn't working so
it was it was the first time in my
career i'd ever done it like that so
it was without doubt the biggest
challenge and it didn't didn't come
naturally to me i would say
um you know i've my favorite part
of recruiting his recruitment still is i
love the buzz of it i love the highs and
lows so
i've had to learn to sort of take a step
back from that and
i still find that hard so i think this
what you're talking about i absolutely
love the fact that you did that i think
that's such a bold move
i think particularly where it was in
your business journey as well to sort of
really
sort of have the balls to go you know
what i shouldn't be the top biller if
this is a business that we want to grow
and turn it into quite quite real
business
um so let's just talk about that for a
second because i think so many people
can get
value out of that mark just because look
you're obviously being part of our dlc
you'll speak to
numerous recruitment business owners but
i think that's one of the biggest
challenges they have right
um in actually going through that
transition so i guess
knowing what you know now obviously
soaking up everything from the rdlc and
learning what you learn
yeah how would you go about
transitioning that differently
or how would you do it would you do it
differently how would you go about it
now if you
if you today was like right heisham
we i need to get off the tools on the
top below that like how would you how
would you go about doing that
well in terms of if i came right so if
they came off the desk and how yeah so
like
because obviously now you've got
obviously the yeah the hindsight
the the learnings from what you learn
the self-development
i guess like yeah how would you go from
right i'm a business owner and i need to
go from not just being a top builder
and being in the business i now need to
sort of transition to
on the business right so how would you
go would you do that and
how would you go about doing that and
would you do it differently i think
you've got to be careful not to throw
the baby out the bath both water um
i think to completely leave your desk
and go right okay you crack on with it
would have been a mistake i think you've
always got one eye on it and i've always
had i've always had one eye on that desk
still because
these relationships i've had for seven
or eight years so i would still do quite
a lot of the
the sales side to it i i might have not
done the actual recruitment but
i knew pretty much and still do every
maintenance engineer the northeast so
if you know if i saw her someone said
what about this guy i'd say about okay
send send to speak to so-and-so so i
still had one eye on the game a little
bit
so i think i still influenced and helped
influence the person who's billing on
that desk quite a bit
but i guess you you've got to look at
what you're good at um and for me that
was probably the
the sales side of it to you know
speaking of people um
and help so that's the bit i went health
leather for so
listening to sales calls um getting them
to listen back to them giving them
feedback on that what could what they
could do better what they could could
differently
um so and and
you've got to place your strengths so
for me that was still speaking of
clients being on the phone
um i would have hated to step steps away
that completely
i think it's always important still to
be the face of the business for as long
as you possibly can do
you've got to make your consultants
famous told me people buy from people
but i still think at this stage you need
to be a a prominent face from the
business so people still trust you
because these but these are mine in gaza
relationships you know
because yeah so how did you communicate
externally than that of interest because
so get that mate so basically so if
you're listening right now and you're in
in the position where mark was
in year three and you want to sort of
start thinking well i want to be on the
business i don't want to be on
just on the tools all the time i
shouldn't be the top biller yeah
so okay i need to have i definitely this
isn't like right somewhere i'm stopping
then you don't do anything it's right i
need to keep an eye on
firstly what what parts of my desk
am i the best at well actually it's cut
off in relationships it's clients blah
blah blah i'm gonna make sure that
i still make sure that goes on and have
an eye on it yeah um
but how so obviously i think that'd be
quite common so i guess
how did you communicate that externally
when people have been used to
dealing with mark i probably
on purpose they didn't i think i tried
to have that a bit of a soft transition
so i think initially when they were
called and speak to me i would say i
would still speak to them
and i would bring along the consult and
we'd have a meeting together so i tried
to try to hold the hand a little bit so
i tried to make that as soft as possible
can do
until they trusted that i was still
there to help without any issues
and then the consulting board would
would do a good job so
it wasn't a big hurrah i'm leaving this
as a person because i think that would
have been a
too big of a risk my sales calls
probably went up because
i was probably in a bubble of speaking
to maintenance managers i was then
speaking to all our clients i'd do more
account management
you know a new client on board i was i
was i had the time to introduce myself
now and
look i'm you know thank you very much
for working with uh vicky i'm the
director
if you need issues come speak to me so i
found myself with more time to do things
like that and nurture and grow the
business
whilst also um getting more involved day
to day um
never on a micronized level but just in
terms of of what people are doing
we've worked on is something that trevor
pinders helps us out with a lot
we've always worked in two-hour sprints
i think it's a perfect way to manage
people so
every two hours it's a very very quick
five minutes what's the plan for these
two next two hours
um great okay i'm gonna i'm gonna try
and
sell so-and-so around what do you want
out of it and you know four or five key
objectives
will touch base after two hours how do
you get how do you get on
why why did you fail why do you succeed
and then you go again so
it's a really easy and quick way to
manage and keeps people focused
because it's so easy to be a busy full
recruitment you can have a day you have
a full day thinking
i've crafted me and if anything what
have i done
but i think if you have those friends
you can clearly go back and see right
okay
these are my non-negotiables these are
my sprints
um and this is what this is what i've
got out of the day so for us that's been
really cool
i love that and then just final thing
before we talk a bit about
sort of the fourth year
so what what did sort of you going
through that transition
enable you to spend time on that you
didn't have
time to do historically so when you say
more on the business
so you've mentioned that enabled you to
focus on
training sales calls helping people
maximize the opportunities that they
were getting
what else did it enable you to do that
obviously i guess you felt really
positive about and
it was great to be able to do i would
say culture
um culture's always been really
important um to
to all to us and and the people we bring
in the business we
we hire on culture more than we do how
much money they're gonna make us you
know when we're open
to them um on an interview about that
course is really important for us so
it enabled me to have a bit of time to
take a step back and look at the
environment we've got and that that goes
from the office you know
and i think it was probably about in the
year three we moved into a
big office space um which you could
completely fit probably 30 people in
there so it's a big space
and that for me it's important to give
people an environment where
it's a stressful environment but to try
and breed stress in the much we possibly
can do
so once they've built um we have a
bushido board which is like a hierarchy
within the company so it's a bit of fun
and incentivize people so as they grow
in the business as they build basically
as they go up
you get um you might get a mobile phone
you get a wireless headset you might get
a computer
your commission screen grows up um but
one of the things
is um you as soon as you build 12 grand
you get a wireless headset which is the
it's the biggest thing where people
start they see people walking around
on the phone playing darts kicking a
football about and just just
you know motion greats emotion all that
so that's a big one for me i wanted to
create an office environment where
people
wanted to come in and work and they
weren't cramped around a small desk you
know around people so
enabled me to spend more time with
things like that we have something
called office vibe
which is free it's a free tool it's
brilliant um and basically it's a
i think it goes out every wednesday to
the guys it's emailed to them
and you can either have random questions
about the business
um or you can actually um select and
choose your questions
and you get anonymous answers about your
business and how you move
brilliant and i i stress to people just
be as honest as you possibly can do
and we've learned a lot from that of
what works or what doesn't
and you know we we asked them to give us
ideas and
a lot of what we've implemented in the
company yeah come from the staff and
event from the start yeah you get much
more buy-in if if someone thinks like
that's my idea you know i
you know that that's something called
office vibe office vibe yeah it's free
it's brilliant um
it's a free tool i think you can get the
premium for other add-ons but what we
need
you get your business gets a rating out
of ten for sort of health and well-being
for professional all sorts of stuff and
you can see which areas you might need
to work on for your business
um it's almost like a psychometric test
for your your company and it's
it's brilliant it's uh it's it's helped
us to
get a culture for us which means people
want to come into work
and we wanted to create an almost like a
work hard
balanced life hard environment you know
we haven't got the play hard you know we
have lunch clubs etc
we have incentives but nothing like that
the business i started off in it's
it's much more i guess autonomous and
relaxed but we want people to come in
and get their head down and graft but um
yeah
short answer would be to sort of spend
time on the i love that because i think
that that's
a big part again that can get left on
the wayside if you're still
staying on the tools and you're a small
grown business so i actually love
sort of what you just shared there
because i think um it's obviously
you always read about culture and
business and
again that could for you in the position
where you was as a business at that
point
you you may deem that as not as
important because
i'll worry about that when there's a few
more of us whatever right and so i
absolutely love that i think that's
great
um so why was year four challenging
so year four was challenging it was
definitely a most challenging year
regarding
it was the year we thought right this is
it as we're going to go for it so
um we we thought we had the process in
place regarding
um you know the kpis and and when the
people who work in the business but
we didn't really think about the process
regarding interviewing we just thought
we could hygro people because so
internal intervention
recruit massively i think looking back
we probably got lucky with the people in
in year
three because year four was a disaster i
think we we ended year four with
the same with six the same six that we
had this would be so common
not being alone yeah so we i think we
had about 10 or 11
who failed miserably um and i think we
we didn't we didn't we didn't file them
quick enough you know we weren't really
used to firing people um so we didn't
file them quick enough
we let people go we we probably hired we
hide on go
um it was subjective we we um we didn't
have a clear
interview strategy in the view structure
what what was it let's just share that
like what was
the theo james interview process at that
point at the time
it was pre i think i think it was two
stage but it was pretty much a meet and
greet in the first stage
and the second time was probably more of
an extensive meet and greet it was more
of a
we chat about the business we chat about
them and then
probably someone said to us at the time
yeah i've i've worked with this company
um this is how much i built we've
probably just got excited and thought
right yeah great they can make a lot of
money we'll bring them in
and if they were nice people our
onboarding process
um was probably non-existent um we
probably expected people to do better
and we brought people in the business
who were either
in hindsight not salesy enough because
we're still quite salesy i think you're
probably too account manager
manager-esque
we brought peeling business who ex-car
salesmen who
sort of talked to a good game but as
soon as he got on the phone he just
crumbled
and and just the wrong motivation so it
was a real
disaster i think we probably knocked a
bit a bit stuffing out of us that that
year because
we probably lost a bit of confidence in
our own ability to to recruit but
it made us go back to basics and and
create a structure
for for this for the year five which has
been
great so far for for hiring and
literally just putting a real
set structure for interviewing
onboarding
and and so forth and and you know
everyone brought in the business so far
has been been a success since that and
i'm really confident though
that's amazing again that's one of those
things which
you could very easily put in the bucket
of i'll do i'll sort out in
our onboarding process when we get to 15
people or whatever do you get what i
mean right
so and and some people just accept or
put up with the
their we tried to we got to 11 staff
and we're now back to seven okay well
next year do you know what i mean so i
love the fact that
you had the humility to be like right
what what have we done here we should
have hide
faster and we hired the wrong people
blah blah blah so you there's a definite
element there you've got to take
responsibility right
so i guess let's just talk about what
what that looks like now because i think
again
this is something that a lot of people
can get value from so how
how did you change your interview
process firstly so more structured so
um so our first stage now um anyone
applies anyone at all applies from from
the website or
however we advertise they get sent a
solo interview
um so we use audro for that so they
basically get sent an email that says
thank you very much for
um for applying for the role this is a
bit about the companies a bit about the
culture so
they get sent some slides about us and
what we do try and get them excited
about it
um the first step for us is a solo
interview so they basically click play
um and they're interviewed themselves
we're not there
i think there's six questions they must
ask so that essentially it's uh it's
like a selfie though video
and they're quite tough questions some
of them are standard ones you know why
would you get into recruitment what your
motivations
there's a horrible question that asks if
you're a kitchen utensil
what would you be and why which is awful
but he froze everyone just i mean
there's a kitchen you tend to what
oh my god and you can see the panicking
people
but you learn the people who have a
laugh with it because it's sales you
don't know what people are going to say
to you
yeah the people who stiffen up and know
what to do you think are they
and the people just either have an
answer you must have got some funny
answers from that
great one people's got a tangent you can
see him thinking
what am i saying here but it's great but
the big one for us is
we get a lot from that because you can
you can get a lot about the personality
and what they're about
but we'll probably only get about 75
balls about 75 percent don't send one
back
and that's fine because yeah cancel them
out straight them out don't you know we
haven't wasted any time though
you know before we'd be on the phone
talking to them and you know we'd waste
hours basically
and we didn't have we didn't hire an
office manager until
year five um so this was this was all us
that was a mistake we made and this was
i took way too much on so um we um
so that's the first fast first data
process um anyone who comes through that
gets um face to face which is typically
me vicki or gary and the consultant and
we stress
to them to personally applying it is
this is your opportunity
to ask us anything to ask us anything
about the business about your job
anything you want will be open and
honest and typically
we try and get them to ask the
consultant about that because we like to
get them involved
and also who better to answer than
someone's working in the business so
that's the first stage second stage is
um
it's two of us so it has to be for it's
it's an owner
um so me and gary or vicky um plus
again another consultant and it's more
structured so
they have to it's a presentation three
slides
uh first is um i think three things
about them
second slide is what your expectations
of the first 12 weeks of working theo
james will be like
and then third is why should we after
that
yeah after that is a uh it's comedy
based questions so scenario based
questions essentially
and then the the one i love is that
after um
on speakerphone they have to sell a cv a
candidate to someone downstairs who's
pretend to be a client
with us watching and it's it's the most
daunting one for them and they know it's
coming up because we
we tell them yeah i i i did that for
one so before i got into equipment i was
in i was an insurance broker
and i had to sell a policy to my that
was going to be my
new hiring man that was going to be my
new manager yeah yeah that is that is
daunting but
what a great exercise great it is great
and because
it's a very selling is different and
face-to-face is very different to
selling the phone
and nine percent of recruitment tell me
still on the phone so
you need to know what i like in that
medium and so that that that's the big
one for us we've got a few people out
doing that um
and because they know they're doing it
we've had people that aren't prepared to
do that second stage and that's again
that's fine
yeah don't waste any time we make a
decision from there
um and then our onboarding process which
trevor pinder
has helped us massively with we make
that word will very small for
probably three or four weeks it's
candidate driven um
they essentially it's finding key pieces
of information from candidates so
it's understanding market it's finding
the good companies to work for
the opinion of the candidate the bad
companies to work for it's getting leads
and it's also gaining very importantly
sort of testimonials
reference names and more testimonials
from candidates of their ex managers
so the essentially building a business
development sheet for them for when they
come off
so you can imagine if people are
successful for that they've then got a
business development sheet to go
spoken to to bill brown he said you're
the best managers ever worked with
i just love that well it's great and it
it's it just it starts the conversation
off on a great foot so
but for us we we see the the good
consultants the hungry consultants from
the from the not so hungry ones there
because
we we're very competitive with a
competitive bunch that's something we
try and hire on
um which is why obviously we have
leaderboards everywhere and it's all
over the tvs
but you see if people want to break the
record they know they can't
make any commission they can't make a
sale or a sales call until they've
finished this project
we call it a darts challenge so they've
got 180 points basically
so they can't finish that project until
they've got 180 points and
the people in the business um the year
five
have just the shift is completely
different because you can there
there were different calibers ones
you've had before well that's honestly
that's
so i love how you even improved that so
much because i'm assuming
what it looked like before that was like
i don't know
not just get on the phones and do this
but it was like here's the database do a
bit of that
get on the phone and speak to a couple
candidates his job you're working on
yeah and that's so
sort of precise it's outcomes driven
there's a real structure to it
you've created competition yeah i love
that that's amazing
i think i think the people the people we
look for are different as well we've
we've seen a we've seen a pattern of the
people we've had successful
we class them as second job is basically
so we don't we don't actually look for
we've got a you know we've got vicky
we've got becky who were
two of the uh or two you know the two
brilliant consultants we've got who are
obviously ex-recruitment but
part of not none of them are have
recruiting experience now we've seen a
pattern of
um of people who um have had
have held a job previously for a couple
of years in some form of a professional
sales role we've had three or four
people from enterprise
cars rental who have been sort of branch
managers so essentially they've actually
come to us with a
a drop in salary and also a drop in
position
because they they've been sold in the
vision that you know as a business now
we're ready to grow
and you know we've now got our level of
our management team and they know
they're part of that so
i think that the people we've hired are
just that step above as well so they've
taken
the onboarding trucks we've got and just
smashed into pieces basically so
that's been a big step up definitely i
love that
that's awesome mate i think you've um
honestly
real great work on that on on really
taking action and getting that sorted um
so let's bring us to today then before
we finish yeah yeah
yeah obviously what obviously you're
sitting in your conservatory right now
working from home yeah
right yeah well um how has it been for
you as a
she clearly did loads of work on getting
the hiring right
for your business and and yeah five now
obviously in in the
the midst of covid what what what have
been some of the biggest challenges for
you
over the last um eight to twelve weeks
so i think i mean
generally year five has had bigger
challenges and in in regards to the
market conditions since we've ever had
brexit was a big challenge um you know
whether
just a scare among them would go on
brexit and the fear facts and people
companies not making decisions people
not making decisions that's had an
impact on
on the market conditions um and we've
seen that and we've
we've had to adapt our business and
we've changed our business we've had to
productize and that's
i think year five is again how we've
changed as a business to try and
adapt the market obviously we've now had
kovid which has been a massive challenge
for every business
i think we i'm really pleased where
we're at at the moment and i think
we could be in a hell of a lot of worst
position the the sort of day it happened
the day sort of all the code was sort of
struck it was it was a really rough day
it was before all the government scheme
scheme came out um
you know we had i think we have 140 live
jobs and every single one of them just
just
just went just when we had now we made
it we made a decision for a business
about six seven months ago to try and
dramatically improve our average fees
and we took people off
um desk boots were working and gave them
brand new desks
but more geographically so looking at
bigger fees
more senior roles at more senior
positions um
which was a big bold move and that was
slowly but surely starting to to work
and the week it happened i think we had
three of those desks all had sort of
eight or ten grand
offers on the table we had about with
about 60 grand of office basically all
canned
just done in two years and we had that
um our biggest contract is worth um
contract weights worth about 20 grand
profit for us a month and it's um
and that that went they were classed as
they basically they do a specialist
coating on the um
on the printer whale ship um a big team
we recruit there
it's obviously worth a lot of money for
us and that they called up and said
because of because of cover 19 that's
got to go
me and guys went over thought wow we've
got decent overheads here like we're
looking at we're looking at zero for
next three months like
we're looking at cash you know we're
looking at decisions big decisions we
might have to make in the business
you know it was it was a grooming time i
probably had really two sleepless nights
where i was a nightmare at home
and um the couple days after that
december the world seemed to sort of put
itself back together
the the contract book they were classed
as key workers so that came back
so their office went through um some of
the deals seem to come back
um i got the team together obviously the
government schemes came out and that
gave us decisions we can make so we
you know we could confidently keep staff
in the business and
i got the team together the day we
decided to work from home and said look
it's going to be grim we've got to make
hey while we can here well no one knows
what's going to happen because this you
know no
it's completely unknown this could be a
12-month thing could be a three-month
thing
we've got we've got to work hard and
stick together um
you know obviously in days to come we we
fill those
bulk of the staff and we kept we kept a
couple i told them we were in it
we weren't in the worst market here
we're in a market that deals with
pharmaceutical
food medical you know we're gonna
there's essential supplies here that
some of our clients are going to need us
thankfully that has been the case you
know we've um we've obviously used the
government schemes
um with fellow staff we've got a loan if
we need it i think we will but hopefully
it's gonna be there and we've had two
three or four clients who thankfully
have been busy than ever to deal with
the demands of cover 19
so i think we've got one company where i
think we've replaced maybe
20 25 engineers within the last last two
months so
we've done pockets of opportunity it's
been it's been a successful time through
us
so he's actually been less stressful
than we ever imagined but i think we've
learned a lot about the business
you know me and gaza got back on the
tools
yeah yeah it's been great it's been fun
it's been it's been
stressful because um i'm back at the top
of the leaderboard oh yeah you know you
sit with the bottom mate but it was i
was um
i'm not sure becky's absolutely
flown so she's at a superb time
basically um gaz
was beating me and he let me know about
it every hour so
you know it's been great to get back to
that so almost day one camaraderie
and remember what it's about so um
although it's been a
stressful situation and no one's any
business to go through it
i think we'll we'll learn a lot more
about the business moving forward and
you know we're incredibly confident that
we will come out this extremely well and
you know we've got zero doubts about for
the first time ever we've got zero
doubts about any of our staff and we've
got some really big plans to the future
now so
amazing the best i've ever felt about
the business i would say and um
before we finish then just thinking of
the time we're recording this there'll
be a lot of people
sort of starting to form their game plan
on returning back to
normal or bats at the office or whatever
so what what sort of been your mindset
and what's share with us a bit of a game
plan as to how
what what the next sort of immediate
couple of weeks look like for you and
your team
we've tried as much as ever to be stick
to business as usual
um we have pledges every morning and
what we're gonna get out of the day
um so we've kept up sort of on on video
we have three meetings three
three very quick meetings a day so we've
kept that up and
so we've tried to keep as the normal
process we possibly can do
and that's what we will sort of continue
trying to do
our conversion rate has gone from 25
or contingency to 70 percent of the last
three months and i think that's
for me giving me a bit of indicator of
you know what
we don't have to work everything you
know we we already do
we productize so we work a certain
amount of of roles um
exclusive and i think that's where we
need to be more now so i think we need
to work with less clients on a more
exclusive basis
a retained basis i think as the market
comes back
i think it will change things and i
think companies will work with
with companies more i think they'll work
very closely
be more selective and they'll be the
look after their cash a lot better
a lot more important on that side so you
need to look now of how you can
productize and give value for the
service you're given so
i think that for us is how we will
change the face the business moving
forward definitely
and what um and then are you playing so
you plan on getting people back in over
the next couple of weeks yeah because
so in the month we uh plan to open the
office um which i think we will do
with no issues and touchwood will um
we're already eight percent staff back
uh unfairly so i think by then we'll be
100 back so
i'm just opening with business as usual
we because we're on a market where we
can adapt we can a change to where the
work is
that's what we'll do you know automotive
has always been quite a big area for us
that's struggling at the moment so it
doesn't make any sense to put a lot of
effort into that
we can work with the clients and the
candidates there to try and help them
which is exactly what we'll do because
you've always got support yeah
you've got clients we've got some
tremendous clients on automotive but it
wouldn't make sense to keep going those
people keep going those people
so we've got to help them but ultimately
we've got now look at the markets that
are moving and
and run with that and i think when
you're a sub 10 company that's easier
i think you're a 100 200 man band it's
different difficult do you mean so we
have the luxury where we can be agile
and adapt quite easily to that
but um and you're making it sort of
optional voluntary for people to come
back in the office but
from the next couple of weeks it's like
right guys doors are open
yeah you've still got as you said the
sort of the
the daily pledges you've got the things
in place and people can do that from in
the office or
obviously uh from home yeah definitely i
mean it'll be
it'd be trial and error i mean we've
never been a work from home we've always
had the capabilities of all
been cloud-based but because i guess
we've worked so hard in the culture of
of being in the office and i want people
to learn from people in the office on
the phone
we've never spoken about you can work
from home we're flexible with it and
someone says look i've got some
tradesmen coming around
fine you know come come in when you can
but this will be the first time wherever
we've
had that option um but i expect people i
think
the general consensus people can't wait
to get back and i think
you know people have missed it i guess
so uh so yeah looking forward i love
that
and look before i ask you the the final
question then mark what are you what are
you most excited about
like just right now or just post covered
professional or personal
what are you most excited about i think
for the first time ever
i felt we have a the strongest team i
could possibly imagine
but also a team where i can see them all
very very quickly be billing managers
and i think as soon as you've got that
base that's when you can
that's when you get to 20 30 40 50 and
so on yeah that's amazing so that's the
plan for us to grow internally
to grow their teams out and also you
know before all this happened
you know we had gary goldsmith um he
comes twice a year
it was brilliant for us and we were
looking at at
different markets we were looking at
looking at jeremy looking at the us so
looking at how we can grow doing what we
do in our niche so
so yeah we've got some really exciting
plans and um yeah so i
i just can't wait to get back to normal
now so we can
get everyone moving and get them booming
so yeah amazing
well look final question you you can
answer this question with a phrase a
word a sentence whatever comes up for
you
and um if mark bracknell could
communicate to every single recruiter
out there or business owner
they'd listen to your advice said take
it on they'd implement it tomorrow
what would you say to the people uh to
the so i'd say initially mindset look
after your mindset because
that's number one and it's so important
to keep checking yourself and keep
positive
and also i guess as a business owner or
as a recruiter
make sure you stand out from what is now
extreme crowder marketplace so utilize
the
platforms and tips you have at your
fingertips so share your opinion online
um utilize that and make sure you be
yourself because people still buy from
people
mark's been absolutely pleasure thank
you